[Music]
oh
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud proud and do not give
a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them
Grandpa poopy pants chickens
out for the last [__] show
circus with the flock of
idiots I don't know I guess that's the
best way to describe it is it I didn't
watch it did you watch it it was on news
nation that [__] ruse they're trying
to be like Fox News light you know what
I mean news Nation they're like no no
we're non-biased we just have people
like Bill O'Reilly on our on our on our
station and we let Megan Kelly be the
moderator of our debate yeah okay
nonbiased news news Nation no really we
are we got Chris Cuomo Chris
Cuomo he's one of our anchors it's great
oh I'm sure it's just [__]
fantastic I didn't watch the [__] show
live cuz who wants to watch that [__]
you can go watch it for free you can
download that news Nation app and watch
that garbage for free if you
want Dan a Dan Abrams is the um is the
was the head honcho until Chris Cuomo
showed up right and they got Bill
O'Reilly on there too you remember that
[__] on news Nation I'm just I'm
just trying to give you a sense of how
credible this debate even
was but you had uh rad damama dingdong
VC and poop Matt really going at it with
Nikki Haley because they're really
terrified that Nikki Haley somehow is
going to you know make it to South
Carolina again I've told you this time
and time and time again Nikki Haley is
betting on South Carolina Ronda Sanz is
betting on
Ohio the bridge gate guy Chris Christie
is betting on New
Hampshire ve ramaswami is just repeating
what's on your Papa's Facebook page the
Russian propaganda all of it now like
he's not even hiding it anymore he's
like yeah I love Putin I want to lick
his balls he's and I he didn't say it
that way he didn't say he wanted to lick
Putin's balls but I mean it sounds like
it he actually accused the other
three candidates who all are Governors
are former governors which is [__]
amazing to me that these [__] people
became Executives in their states these
[__] Bon heads
who can't even say [__] Trump's name
besides Chris
Christie and it's Chris Christie's main
personality trait right now to be
anti-trump which I'm not against Chris
Christie's one of the best at this when
you talk about smashing Trump he's hell
of a lot better than [__] Liz Cheney
is hell of a lot [__] better at it
honestly if the Republicans pluck their
head out of their ass and realized that
they had a winner in the race against
Joe Biden they would realize they should
nominate Chris Christie but you think
these dumb [__] are going to
come to their senses anytime soon hails
to the no that's right I said it I said
it out loud and I know it's going to
piss a lot of people off but I don't
give a [__] Chris Christie would beat
Joe Biden in a [__] race
folks yes he would you can say what you
want to say but that's why Joe Biden is
saying the only reason why I'm in this
race is because Trump's in the race cuz
I can beat that [__] and that's
my service to the country is to beat the
pants off that [__] fascist that want
to be
dictator so why have Chris Christie in
the race if Joe Biden can beat him right
I mean that's kind of the idea but again
they're not going to come to their
senses they're not going to realize this
stuff because it's a [__] cult it's a
[__]
cult and there was no more prime example
last night than VC radama
ding-dong carrying on and licking the
boots of Donald Trump he even said it
one Point [__] said these people
are one-time
bootlickers I'm a full-time bootlicker
[__] he literally said I mean
not exact words but you know that' be my
[__]
words that he's licking the boots of day
one dict
taster day one dict
taster dictator sorry I keep getting
that confused whenever I think of trump
I think dictator but dictat comes out
and I guess it maybe appropriate that
way especially when you're talking about
V Rama radama
dingdong licking the boots of the of the
day one dict
taster it's [__] insane that I even
get to say these
words it's crazy that I'm able to turn
this microphone microphone on and say
the [__] I'm saying in the order that
I'm saying it never has these words been
able to be used in this order in this
way in this context before in history
and here we [__]
are because the Republican Party are a
bunch of [__] darli
[__] it's [__]
pathetic it really
is how [__] pathetic is it and I
honestly they're backed into a corner
here I don't know if you noticed but our
narrative is [__] working folks
they're on the defense like a some [__]
even the [__] people running against
Trump have to defend him on
stage against a a a person who claims
he's known Trump for 20 years and he's
good friends with him they went to each
other's houses and had dinner together
he said that [__] Chris Christie said
that
[__] what I I don't know what you want
from me I just I'm just [__] here to
tell you what the hell's going
on uh the day one dictor excuse me
dictator God I I need to I need get a
handle on
that is in court this morning uh because
he he wasn't at the debate last night so
he's trying to book in the debate with
news I don't know if you noticed that so
the day before the debate he declared
players he wants to be the dictator on
day one when he's elected and they
cheered him yay on handed his show yay
yay yeah we want you to be a
dictator and they're they're claiming
it's about the border and [__] but
listen they're on the [__] run and
they're on the defense on this dictator
stuff and the Nazi stuff all over
right-wing media all over right-wing
media and I'm talking about deep
right-wing media I'm not talking about
Fox News not the [__] that your papa
watches I'm talking about the [__]
tenf hat [__] the crazy
[__] they're having to defend that Trump
isn't a Nazi they're like look look you
Nazis out there that are listening to
this program because that's pretty much
that all that listens to this program is
a bunch of [__] Nazis we're going to
explain to you why you're not Nazis and
why it should hurt your feelings when
someone points out that you're a Nazi
that's literally what they're doing
rightwing
right-wing sludge
media is absolutely painted themselves
into a [__] fascist Corner that's not
our [__] problem how is that our
[__] problem they blame it on the
left they're like oh the left and the
left this and the left that well if
you're the opposite of the left okay
well let me let me give you [__] [__]
eating right- Wingers out there a
[__] lesson and how the [__]
pendulum Works in political ideology
okay let me give you a quick [__]
lesson the opposite of the left is what
what is it what is it what what is the
opposite of the left it's the right you
stupid
bastards and there's no there's
no ideology out there that is more
quintessential than ex right-wing
extremism then fascism you [__]
boneheads if you're you're a
right-winger and you hate the left you
hate communist you hate socialist you
hate moderate that appear to be
socialist or just even talk about things
like minimum wage and decent wages and
not going broke because of a medical
bill and highways can you imagine paying
taxes for highways and education and
schooling for children in this country
God that smells like communism you're a
right Winger dumb
[__] you're a [__] right
winger that's that's the
opposite I I I I can't H I can't tell
you how frustrating it is that this
country doesn't understand ideology and
it's not just the right the right is
[__] boneheaded on this stuff and
really honestly a lot of them believe
right-wing [__] and they don't even know
that it's right-wing even when they say
the [__] out loud like I hate the left
I'm the opposite of the left that makes
you right you stupid
[__] but the left has problems with this
too [__] yesterday we watched his Ivy
League schools went and testified
couldn't figure out that you really
shouldn't [__] you really shouldn't
[__] be a university and promoting
and allowing people to call for the
genocide of Jews on your campus probably
not a thing that you should do as a
school right I mean I get it that
schools want to promote freedom of
speech but this is the dumbest [__] I've
ever heard of in my life folks listen on
a school campus on a school campus they
control that campus and you cannot have
one group of students calling for the
genocide of another group of students
you stupid
[__] I get that you want to promote
freedom of
speech but that is not what it is when
you have a group of students in your
school that are enrolled in your school
calling for the genocide of another
group of students in your [__]
University you stupid
bastards how in the i i i i i one of
these days I promise you one of these
days this show is gonna get big and
everyone's gonna listen to it and it'll
wake a lot of [__] up to the
same [__] you this audience has woke up
to just common [__] sense it's common
[__] sense how don't you know what
the freedom of speech is how don't you
know what the first amendment is how
don't you know these
things yes you have the right to
believe and hate Jew you can hate Jewish
people you can [__] hate them and you
can you can deny the Holocaust you can
call for the genocide of
people in a forum that allows you to
with your first
amendment okay on a University campus
calling for the genocide side of another
group of students is not the venue
dummy that's not the [__] venue and
for and for Yale and Harvard or whoever
the [__] it was these IB Le schools that
are supposed to be creme day crem you
know I've I've gotten a lot of flack for
saying that it's not that hard to be an
attorney in this country and it's not I
I don't give a [__] I don't give a [__]
you can come at me you can be mad at me
when I say this it is not that hard to
be a [__] attorney in this country
you do not have to be smart it is now
obvious that you don't have to be smart
to be a [__] attorney in this
country there are smart attorneys don't
get me wrong there's good professional
smart attorneys that know what the [__]
they're doing and they're
professionals and and and they're great
at what they do they're very good at it
don't get me
wrong but you don't have to be [__]
smart to be an attorney holy [__] and
obviously you don't have to be [__]
smart to run a university either holy
[__] are you kidding
me every group on the University campus
should feel welcome on that University
campus I don't give a [__] if they're
[__] muslim if they're Jewish if
they're Catholic if they're Protestant
if they're [__] atheist if they're
siks if they're [__] Satanist I don't
give a [__] everyone on that [__]
campus is allow Liv Liberty through that
campus's
bylaws that campus controls that campus
that University controls that campus
[__] their students are
enrolled in their school now I'm not
saying that they have to [__] that
they have to censor
people okay they don't have to S you
don't have to censor people but when you
get in a situation where you have a
group of students calling for the
genocide of another group of students
you're in you're in a total [__] gray
area and for you just not to realize
that you're in a gray area of freedom of
speech and acknowledge it and make a
decision on it you are a piece of trash
and these and these University
presidents that are [__] apologizing
for the statements in this testimony
should [__] resign immediately
immediately gone [__] you [__] you
gone it's enough of this stupid ass [__]
where we're going to we're going to prop
up islamophobia or anti-Semitism I don't
give a [__] which one it is there ain't
a war going on in this [__] country
folks this country you had the freedom
of [__] religion that's why we don't
have religious wars here that's why
white Christian nationalists are so
[__] wet in the pants to [__] make
this a fascist Nation because they want
religious wars here that's what the [__]
they want more people get killed in the
name of religion than any other [__]
reason mainly that is the [__] reason
that people get [__] slaughtered
killed and genocide and Holocaust
happened is [__] religion and if you
don't know that and if you can't come to
the truth of that I don't give a [__]
what your faith is and how much you
believe in whatever [__] spaghetti
monster in the sky that you [__]
believe in if you can't come to that
truth and you're not being [__]
you're not being a a genuine de
B and you're not pro and you're not
you're not [__] protesting in good
faith
either prop
Palestinian protesters protesting and
and calling I don't give a [__] if you
don't know what it means I don't care if
you're saying some [__] you saw on Tik
Tock or Facebook or the tubes of you or
wherever the [__] you heard this [__]
some video on the internet told told you
from the river to the Sea and it makes
sense I don't give a [__] if you don't
understand it you are calling for the
genocide of Jewish
people in the name in the name of of a
ceasefire to stop killing Palestinian
children that BB Netanyahu is [__]
killing you're going to call for the
[__] extermination of Jewish people
oh oh okay yeah that makes a lot of
[__] sense
bonehead there is no religious War here
there's a [__] reason there's no
[__] religious War here folks our
constitution gives us that
ability in the Middle East in the Middle
East all those countries don't have the
freedom of [__] religion besides one
of them one of them and they do have
have a sanctioned religion in their
country but you still have the freedom
to have another religion and it's the
Democracy of Israel no matter how
[__] no matter how [__] right-wing
that government has become and how
ignorant they are to keep right-wingers
and people who oppress Palestinians in
the [__] West Bank and take their
[__] land and have illegal settlement
there and bomb and kill needlessly kill
children in [__] Gaza so that they
can [__] get Hamas
which they should but they're they're
doing it all the wrong
ways they're the only ones the only ones
where you have the
freedom try going to an Arab
world and practicing your religion
openly and freely without the threat of
[__] death try it do it I dare
you have you heard of Isis before
have you heard of Isis you pramas
[__] that's right that's right
if you're if you're speaking about about
the Palestinian people and you're and
you're not being very very clear about
what your stances on the liberty of the
Palestinian people because I believe
that the Palestinian people should have
real Liberty not [__] Liberty where
they're oppressed by
Hamas that's [__] that's [__] Hamas
is a [__] group of Theocratic fascist
dummies and if you're speaking out
against fascism here in this country and
you can't put two and two together and
know that that's what that is over there
you're a dumb [__] that's what you are
you're believing propaganda your brain
is on but it ain't
working I don't care if you're on the
left or right I don't care what evidence
you send me I don't care what history
you
think
I don't give a [__] there's a reason why
there's not religious war in this
country there's a
reason and we don't need no [__]
religious War you take your religious
war and you can stick it up your [__]
ass because we got the freedom from
religion in this country that's right
the freedom from religion you don't get
to tell me what what I'm going to
believe because you believe it you can
believe whatever the [__] crazy ass
[__] you
want but you don't get to [__] tell
me what I get to [__] believe or
don't
believe that's why we don't because we
have that freedom and that Liberty here
that's why we don't have religious wars
it's the reason why again the right-wing
and the Christian white nationalists
want a religious War Jesus Christ Ronda
santis was on Fox news this morning
talking about children chopping off
their private parts Hey Ron Hey Ron are
you [__] circumcised
buddy did you get the end of your dick
cut off when you were a baby were was
your [__] genitalia mutilated huh
this is all stupid [__] it's ridiculous
these [__] people are not serious and
they're not doing this [__] in good
faith and last night that debate was not
in good
faith it's not even Chris Christie I
know it's it's good to cheer him on and
be a big Chris Christy cheerleader
because these [__] Chris Christie
Clips are gold absolute
gold and they're going to be they're
going to be gold coming going into the
general election when Chris Christie has
to make a choice and stand before the
American people and say if he's gonna
vote for Joe Biden or if he's gonna vote
for Donald
Trump oh it's gonna be [__] beautiful
Mah and we should leverage every single
[__] word that he said says against
all of them [__]
them but it's just
crazy it's crazy to
me that they don't see the Republicans
the voters the party the donors for
crying out loud they went to Nikki Haley
that lying piece of [__] yeah she's a
lying piece of [__] she ain't no better
than
VC she turns her [__] position she
flips her position whenever it's
convenient for her and whatever crowd
she's in front of she [__] talks
about [__] that's that's Russian
propaganda all the [__]
time and then she's like no I didn't say
that I changed my mind same as VC and
then you got [__] poop Matt Ron holy
[__] this guy God
damn Ron dude drop the [__] out man
actually no stay in the race I I got to
be honest the reason why I want Ronda
Santos Ronda Santos to stay in the race
is because his followers are still
following him and and they're they're
exposing MAA who they used to be who
they are because they know who they are
because that's who they were and who
they still are if you want to know the
honest truth and I can't wait for more
for more Ronda Santa supporters to turn
back to Maga and beg for their [__]
forgiveness which they will and it'll be
beautiful because it'll only [__]
break their vote up
it'll only break their vote
up and if they had any kind of [__]
sense about them Republican voters MAA
anyone really on the right they would
[__] realize what I realized when I
watched the debate the clips of the
debate last night I didn't watch the
debate I just watched the clips [__]
watching that [__] I'm not giving news
Nation my [__] ratings [__]
them but when I watched the clips of the
debate last last night I have to tell
you Chris Christie would beat Joe Biden
in a in a general election race folks he
certainly would Joe Biden wouldn't stand
a
chance wouldn't I know it feels bad for
me to say that and people don't want me
to say that and they don't want to hear
that folks he
would there's something about that
stupid tough guy thing that this [__]
country loves I don't know what it is I
don't know why it is but it is
[__] it's the reason why they were
enamored by Trump because he he was he
was a birther remember that went after
Barack Obama because of his burst tiity
that tough guy [__] that tough guy act
how he's going to send people down to
Hawaii and then he went to get judge our
pyro in Arizona which isn't even close
to
Hawaii help he's going to get judge rpio
to help him uncover that Barack Obama
wasn't born in this country and now that
bull [__] all that racist [__]
tropes that tough guy act you know what
I mean and then the tough guy act when
he was in
2016 against against the email lady and
then he tried in 20 2018 it didn't work
for him we won back to [__]
Congress then it didn't work for him in
2020 he really [__]
failed by the biggest margin in
history and he's GNA win by the next
biggest margin in history in
2024 cuz if we can't beat this [__]
[__] if we can't beat this [__] folks
we need to look Inward and I know it
feels like we need to look outward but
godamn we're talking about 81 million
versus 73 million at a bare minimum bare
minimum those are the numbers that's the
math and that's the math that you need
to make sure that these [__] idiots
don't get the the [__] their grubby
little fascist hands on our [__]
democracy he he he he truth yesterday
that he's more he he he'll protect
democracy more than Biden Oh I thought
it was a
republic so anytime you get some dumb
[__] in your comments who's some kind of
maanga saying it's not a democracy it's
a republic take that screen grab and
just see if see if Donald Trump has been
told by these [__] [__] eaters that
it's not a democracy it's a
republic that's right there's an
argument right there I know I know it
feels weird to do that argument to use
Trump's words to prove your point in the
way that it's a democracy because he's
saying it's a democracy but hey
sometimes you just got to do the [__]
you got to do to [__] win and that's
all I'm advocating for is just do the
[__] we got to do to [__] win and if
that mean if that means I gotta [__]
pound on Liz Cheney and and and Chris
Christie for being anti-trump now that's
right folks I I'm telling you I know I
know it doesn't feel like it but me
pounding and beating on Liz Cheney and
Chris Christie is good for Joe Biden and
democracy it is I know I don't feel like
it right now but it is trust me it is it
will be these people can't help
themselves these fascists can't [__]
help themselves why do you think Chris
Chris's in this race he can't
win he can't he can't [__] win
CU he can't attract this vote this manga
cult he can't get them to [__] turn
on the cult leader especially when he's
saying your cult leader is [__] you need
a new cult leader you need me your cult
Leader's a [__] idiot they're not
gonna buy that [__] they're not they're
not in advanced cultism yet hell they're
just in its
infancy he can't win and and LZ Chene is
going to try to get in this race because
they can't they
cannot help themselves these fascists
and that's right LZ Jan is a [__]
fascist you can swing it however you
want it I don't care a fascist is a
fascist is a fascist and that's what she
is she always has been always will be
just because she's not the top fascist
and she wants to be the top fascist so
she's attacking the top fascist come
on I'm telling
you that is going to help us with our
messaging not hurt us I've had a lot of
people say Tony You're Gonna Hurt they
gonna hurt messaging a narrative because
Liz sheney is on our
side she's not on our side you dumb
[__] she just hates Trump so let
her hate Trump what do I care hate Trump
[__] yeah hate him Chris Christie hate
him go on stage say all kinds of crazy
[__] about him the crazy [__] that I
said here and say say it yeah great but
I don't have to be your [__]
friend I always say the enemy of your
enemy is your friend and that is a bunch
of [__] don't believe that
garbage that's a bunch of [__] and
you don't come here for [__] you
come here for the real raw truth in a
strategic way to give you that cathartic
release to point your outrage to save
your democracy and engage in it every
single weekday Monday through Friday
newon Easter 11 Central 9 Pacific we're
like 100 away from 20,000 here at the
Tony Michaels podcast I know that sounds
weird we should have like 200,000 but
we're only 100 away from 20 so get on
the Subscribe button right now hit that
[__] button
[__] and give me a thumbs up or
a thumbs down if you hate this thing
just just subscribe that's all I ask
even if you hate it just hit the [__]
subscribe button let's Show YouTube who
we're who we
are and I I wantan to uh give thanks to
everyone out there who's participating
on Discord and the the book club the
library of democracy is is sponsoring
the book club they're going to be
reading win every argument with Min
Assan go to the Tony michaels.com that's
Theon michaels.com let me show you where
to go you go right here you hit
subscribe at the top of the page you pan
down and boom there's the [__] book
club right there you got to join the
Discord but it's worth it joining this
book club because I'm telling you they
listen to the audio
book of Rachel mat and we're also going
to be doing the
book of Dr Rachel boffer and she's going
to participate in that book club
discussion with her
book so make sure make sure to go join
the book club today at the Tony
michaels.com and don't go anywhere we'll
be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacist the first lesson began
with learning simple phrases and soon I
was putting those words and phrases into
a conversation each lesson takes about
10 to 15 minutes to complete and they're
all really different which keeps things
interesting the app is really smart it
actually keeps track of the words that
I'm struggling with I chose Babel magga
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new Maga skills with my in-laws all
lives
matter jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast I got a plenty of clips of these
[__] idiots to show you from last
night
especially be radama Dingo and poop Matt
Bron and then we're going to watch some
clips of Chris Christie absolutely
[__] burning down Trump's
house and I'm going to explain to you
why we should make sure that Chris
Christie doesn't win this primary that
is something we do not want it's Chris
Christie to win this Prim excuse
me h
I'm almost over this stuff I promise
I've almost got my voice back 100% I
don't know if you noticed that but I
still got a little bit of a congestion
and a cough going on just a little bit
just a little bit but it's getting
better it's getting better every single
day what the I what sh I don't know what
the hell that was I got plenty of Clips
to show you I didn't mean to hit that
button I promise it happens sometimes I
don't know Tony sucks Gabe rocks
right but I got plenty of clips to show
you today of these these [__] that
were on stage last night um one of the
[__] that was obviously not there
was Grandpa poopy pants the day one
dictor I mean dictator I've also got a a
great
clip from U Trey Crowder to show you
about him being a dictator and he had a
little different take on the word
dictator than I do but you know that's
how it goes sometimes so I'll be showing
you that but let's do this let's shoot
this [__] as I get these U
as I get these these clips queued up
here and you guys can ask a question in
the chat go ahead and ask the questions
in the chat and then we're gonna shoot
the [__] for a minute I like to shoot
the [__] um with you guys Naomi says
Gabe walks I don't know did Gabe get his
I I didn't get to watch the show
yesterday I got busy after the show um
did he get his car back maybe we'll ask
him today if he comes on if he got his
car back big staff on on Twitch says
Tony did you drink last
night it was a Wednesday of course I did
I had plenty of Jagger Meister last
night and I tried to sing I it was all
right it was all right it was all right
I I wasn't 100% yet my singing voice
isn't back on and I gotta sing in a in
in those low songs you know what I mean
but it it worked out it worked out um
Michelle says she's sick too Tony
Michaels yeah a lot of people are sick
right now it's that time of year you
know what I mean I get I get the sign of
stuff you know once or twice a year and
it lasts a couple weeks now Monday was
the worst day for my voice I don't know
if you guys noce that but Monday was the
worst day Sunday Sunday might have been
worse but I didn't talk a lot because I
was trying to save my voice for Monday
but it it is coming back I've almost got
it back 100% um and and I don't strain
to talk but I still have that little bit
of a coughing fit every once in a while
so it happens like that um namely says
gate walks but Chris B says Texas Paul
toots now there's fartgate going on in
there oh the good old
fartgate uh let's see what else have we
got in the chat here you guys are the
best audience in the world you guys
never never let me down in the T in in
the chat um Pam Matthews says just the
tip I don't know what you mean by just
the tip you're asking a question here
what does that mean um are you leaving a
tip are you just putting the tip in I
don't know you can put it in the tip jar
speaking of that if you want to you want
to get technical you can go to the Tony
michaels.com you can put the tip in the
swear jar just put the tip in just the
tip Pam just the tip in the swear jar if
you want or you can buy me a shot of
Jagger if you'd like to do that oh boy
oh boy now let's see what else do we got
here you got any other questions um
someone asked on Twitch did you sing
yeah I sing
um uh Paul Young says does a shark [__]
in the sea I mean a bear shits in the
woods unless they're in a zoo right is a
zoo considered the woods is a shark tank
considered the sea Paul I don't know so
I mean they can [__] in a shark tank and
they can [__] in the sea you know what I
mean so it's possible it's not possible
Pam here on Twitter says Jagger uh
tastes like cough medicine maybe that's
why I like it which why I have a special
place in my heart for Jagger it does
help though I'm not going to lie like
like when you have a cough like I've got
that that Jagger like it's real thick
and it goes down your throat and it
warms your throat and kind of sues your
throat a little bit um as buds here on
YouTube says Gabe has a rental so he
finally got a rental car huh he must
have worked out the U the insurance part
of it maybe we'll ask him about it if he
comes on the show today I think he might
be coming on the show I know he's going
to do a show if it's Thursday so he
should be doing a show this afternoon
after this show on YouTube and twitch so
maybe we'll maybe we'll get to ask Gabe
about his uh about his car situation
Jane Doe here on YouTube says you always
sound like an angel Tony oh an angel is
this what Angels sound like I don't know
I don't believe in heaven but if I did
this is the voice that I would give
them that's what I would um Susan asked
Tony do you think Trum will get rid of
the legislative branch of government and
that that'll be very difficult but what
he is going to do is uh he's going to
follow project 20125 and the reason why
is because he doesn't have any real
original ideas he just he just [__]
says what everyone else is telling him
to say right I this guy isn't as smart
as we think but he's not as dumb as we
think either right A lot of people get
that Twisted you know they think he's
got dementia and his mind's going
because he he says Obama when he's
talking talk about the president but
again a lot of this [__] that he says it
sounds confusing it sounds weird and
it's just off-the-wall [__] he's
speaking q andon and I don't know if
you've listened to these qinon freaks
speak but when they speak it sounds
really [__] dumb so when he's
speaking
qinon he sounds really [__] dumb so
um but back to the legislative branch
it's going to be really hard for him to
get rid of the legislative branch
because it's in our constitution see
that's the whole point of project 2025
is to use our democracy against our
democracy to undermine the the judicial
branch and the legislative branch right
now our constitution if you actually go
back and look at the historical context
of our constitution gave way less power
to the executive the president of the
United States and the executive branch
than we do today honestly I think that's
one of the problems that we have with
our government and our democracy it's
one of the one of the main underpinnings
that we miss right because uh and it's
it's kind of like you know and I've
talked about this before about like term
limits H which is all [__] term
limits is [__] nonsense when you're
talking about the legislative branch of
government it really is now I'm not
saying I don't believe in term limits
for the executive obviously we we need
to have um those term limits on our one
executive that we have in this country
for our federal government but um also
maybe considering different ways to to
make sure to seat judicial nominees and
judges on federal benches I'm not
against that kind of talk but when you
talk about term limits on the
legislative rant specifically the House
of Representatives those [__]
serve twoyear terms and if we actually
gave those two-year term Representatives
back more power away from the executive
that we have just kind of handed over to
the executive year after year after year
Administration after Administration if
we draw that back to the legislative
power that puts the power back in our
pockets because every two years we get
to change that [__] body of
government every two years not every
four years not every six years like the
Senate and not a lifetime appointment
like [__] Federal Judicial uh
appointments okay
every two [__] years we get to fire
those son of a
[__] and that's the
key right that's the key to our
representation that's why the House of
Representatives the one half of the
legislative branch controls
appropriations because it's our money
it's ours it's our tax dollars we
[__] pay it we we we vote them in to
go represent us to appropriate the funds
that we pay in taxes it's really [__]
simple stuff like it's not hard to
understand our form of government it
really isn't I mean there's a lot of
complicated things that happen with the
House of Representatives the Senate
passing a bill moving a bill through
committees once the bill is passed in
both
Chambers getting the bill to the
president's desk sometimes is a
difficult legislative
process when you have to use the
stitution to guide you the
parliamentarian has to use the rules to
make sure that it's done properly and
it's constitutional and legal before it
gets to the desk of the president of the
United States rather they sign it or
veto it all that shit's important it's
kind of complicated but it isn't
complicated to know how our system of
government works and how our power Works
in our government because we is the
government we is the government and
there's no there's no better examp
example of that than the body of the
House of
Representatives really isn't so when you
ask uh do I think Trump will get rid of
the legislative branch the answer to
that is no um a couple different ways
number one he will never be the
president of United States again I am
very [__] confident of that I'm not
one of these people who are afraid of
trump that's the that's the [__]
mainstream media if you want if you want
[__] content that's scar to Trump go
to [__] other left Wingers and other
[__] mainstreamers who are trying to
get clicks and likes and all that
[__] who are terrified of trump all
that 14th Amendment talk and all that
[__] over there where they're
[__] terrified of trump I'm not
scared of that [__] neither
should you be you got the power to vote
[__] you got the power it's
yours you got the power to use your
First Amendment right to engage in your
democracy that's what you have you have
those [__] Powers you have those
[__] rights why the [__] are you
scared of trump [__] him [__] that weak
ass little
[__] we should not be terrified of that
son of a [__] honestly we should be
[__] cheering that he's the easiest
to beat because he is he's the easiest
[__] to
beat he's telling us he wants to be a
dictator I mean a
dictator saying it out loud [__] they're
having to defend him on right-wing media
that ah he's not a Nazi we're not listen
listen to my Nazi followers out there
you're not as Nazi as they're saying you
are there it's going to be easy folks I
know it feels like you know it's like an
uphill battle and oh man oh man it's a
huge threat and it is a threat to our
democracy I'm not denying that it is the
biggest threat to your rights and your
freedom I don't know if you notice what
the [__] they're trying to do in some of
these red States but that's what they
want to do on a federal
level they can get elected and they can
get power in these in these [__] red
States and they can [__] they can
show you what they're doing and what
they want to do with our
nation so Susan no he can't get rid of
the legislative Brands because he can't
be president again because we stand in
his [__] way and even if he was
president he's not [__] smart enough
to understand how the [__]
legislative branch even
works let alone how to get rid of it but
what he will do is he will undermine the
administrative State and they will do
anything they can to oppress people in
this country using the government as
their tool and if that means that they
will weaken the legislative branch they
will do
that and they will do it as fast as they
possibly [__] can because the faster
the better because they're losing
they're losing the war on people loving
democracy they truly are so uh great
question exuse great
question uh Timothy says what happened
to gab's car that's a good question
Timothy we're not really sure it just
[__] went missing it just went
missing we're not sure if it got stolen
or if it's part of a George Santos fraud
scheme we're not
really we're not really sure not really
sure now what other questions do you got
here Susan ask another qu oh no that's
the same one sorry about that I the chat
there's so many there's so much stuff in
the chat there's so much stuff in the
chat H Grumpy Cat here says Texas Paul
is the owner of a lonely fart I don't
know it sounded like it to me he accus
did you notice he accused me of changing
this I didn't change the sound you can
go look at his channel and look at that
little clip I didn't change the sound
fartgate continues fartgate
continues oh
boy what else do we got
here
um theren says where did t i Tony go oh
that's a good question there where did I
Tony go so um I I like this question
because I was putting out articles on
patreon through iony now it was a really
really hard roundabout way but we are
building uh we are training a new we I
training what is it red is it is it
training yeah is it training or what
what what are we doing are we training a
new iony are we building a new iony what
is it are we like refining the brain of
a new iony we all know my brain needs to
be [__] refine and need some you know
new new programming but we're we're
program that that's a good that's a good
way of putting it right good way but
yeah yeah it's a good way of putting it
we're programming a new iony um so once
we get that iony released there's going
to be a lot more stories and um we're
hoping it gets to the point to where
actually you can actually use the iton
yourself so like if you want to know
what I would say about a story you can
go like feed it and be like hey what
would Tony say about this story and then
it'll [__] out the thing that I would
say about that story or whatever but AI
the problem is is that AI well it's not
a problem it's it's just timing so AI is
it takes a little bit of time to get
where you need it to do what you want to
do with it because you gotta [__]
train it so it's a good question Daren I
like that question I'm glad you asked I
Tony will be making its return I Tony
will be making its return I don't know
if that's a is that like Terminator I'll
be back I'll be
back I Tony will return let's see what
other questions do we got here in the
chat I love shoot this [__] I like
talking to you guys in the chat
sometimes it's hard to keep
up with the chat um what do I think
about micro Johnson oh well I'm gonna
Microsoft Johnson I'm gonna I'm gonna
show you a clip today of micro Johnson
talking about how I mean we all know
this guy's a white Christian nationalist
right and everyone was so scared of this
guy becoming speaker because he was a
white Christian nationalist I'm like no
we need an overt white Christian
nationalist to be in this kind of power
to show you the [__] reason why you
shouldn't have them there like all these
hypotheticals that you give right all
the hypotheticals that you give because
I was reading part of the Atlantic and
watching some interviews on The
Atlantics AR article about how Trump
will be the next Hitler and they give
all these [__] hypotheticals and all
this [__] about his
hypotheticals here's the thing you don't
need hypotheticals they're telling you
what they want to do you don't need to
be like well if he's elected this is
going to happen like no here's what he's
saying maybe you should pay attention to
what the [__] he's saying when you use
your vote that's pretty simple that's
pretty simple oh let's see what else do
we have
here
Spicy Dragon says good morning and happy
Hanukkah happy
Hanukkah don't say happy holidays boy
you really get people upset uh let's see
what else do we got
here now oh oh someone's asking if I'm
um Brad says Tony when is your stent in
Zuck goong over I'm not really sure it's
hard for me to [__] figure that out
if you want to be
perfectly honest I I don't I don't know
I don't know I don't know if it'll ever
I don't know if it ever
happen I don't know if it'll ever happen
to be quite honest
um um yvet says no you're on point Tony
I will never doubt you I mean you should
doubt me to some degree like you should
use your thinky space right you should
use your thinky space and um give some
doubt I mean it what what doubt does
because Doubt's a good thing Doubt's not
a bad thing right that's why I say doubt
me I'm telling you to doubt me because I
I I need you to challenge yourself to
[__] come up with the ideas in your
thinking space to to manage to put
together enough logical thought and use
your critical thinking skills to come to
a conclusion that's the whole point
that's the whole point that's why I want
you to doubt me I want you to doubt me I
want you to figure out if I'm right
maybe Tony is wrong [__] I don't know go
look it up go try to figure out if I'm
wrong go try to prove me wrong because
when you when you look at an idea and
you're like ah that sounds like a bunch
of [__] and then you go try to prove
it wrong and it proves
right maybe they're on to something I
don't know
so I don't think you should never doubt
me and I appreciate the the great
comment because I appreciate the love as
always um but you maybe just just a
little bit just a little bit of Doubt
not never just a little bit of Doubt um
oh my God ah I started something with
fart gate that won't be undone I don't I
think
um I'm just I'm I'm scared it might leak
into Texas Paul's chat I don't
know far gate I think he took it pretty
good I think he took it pretty good
right I don't I don't know if it that I
just pulled the sound that someone sent
me El Howard says Texas Paul lives in
the lone fart
State H the good news is is Texas Paul
is part of our army not The Shard Army
so his farts are on our side folks
that's right his farts are for Freedom
so you Texas Paul knows I love him and
it's all in good fun
um um this is a weird um buil player for
B I guess is what your handle is here on
YouTube how do you deal living in Trump
country there in Missouri I I
mean I mean if you want to know the
honest truth in Trump country there's
not a lot of people that are overtly for
Trump
anymore there were there were years ago
like during the 2020 cycle there was a
ton of [__] Trump lags there were a
ton of people that would have Trump
signs in your yard they'd be driving
around with their [__] trucks with
their stupid [__] Trump legs that
doesn't really exist that much anymore I
mean you got the [__] silly little
incel [__] that still have the Trump
flags that they're flying right and you
still have the [__] DieHard cult
members that's why I tell you you guys
shouldn't be so [__] worried about
this [__] that's the biggest lie he's
ever [__] told us that's the biggest
lie that anyone has ever [__] rained
down on this country is that Trump has
some kind of massive support that's all
[__] [__] that's
[__] he literally he literally does
not have the support that everyone
believes he has even us he doesn't it's
all
nonsense um so how do I live here in
Trump country well I mean I run into him
every once in a while but I I I kind of
come at him the way I come at him at the
show and I've got some friends that that
you know will vote for that son of a
[__] and the thing that I do is I just
question them I question them question
and some my friends get mad because
they're like oh Tony you always think
you're right like I I'm always wrong and
you're always right I'm like I'm not I'm
not saying I'm correct I'm just asking
you questions and when you answer the
question you can't [__] come back at
me that's the problem that you have it's
not my problem that you can't answer a
simple question these aren't my problems
these are your problems not mine I'm not
a [__] Biden shill I'm not some kind
of worshipper of [__] political
figures it isn't something I do I don't
have [__] Biden stickers or Biden
Flags behind me I don't wear a Biden hat
on my show I don't even [__] shill
for Biden if you want to know the honest
truth I've said Biden more in the past
30 seconds then I have all [__]
week they can't stop [__] worshiping
MAA and trumpism and Nazism and [__]
fascism so but it's few and far between
that do that
[__] A lot of people that are going to
vote for him are going to vote for him
because of Association I've talked about
this before they don't really like that
[__] they don't they want that
[__] to go away they would be
happy if he just [__] choked on a
cheeseburger and was gone before he
[__] hit the ground they would be
happy about it because then they can
move on with their lives without having
to defend his dumbass because of their
association with the Republican
party so I
mean there's that but that's how I
survive I guess I mean I don't give a
[__] either like I don't care if you
have your beliefs you're welcome to have
your beliefs but you damn well better
bet I've got my beliefs and I'll [__]
defend them like I'll defend my position
I don't give a [__] I do not give a [__]
who you are who you think you are where
you live where you think you live where
you're from I will defend my [__]
position and you should too and that's
that's like that's the
main premise of the show sort of is for
you guys to be able to go out there and
use some of this [__] to go defend your
position right all right let's see what
else do we have here I love shoot this
[__] we should do this more often you
know we should make like a [__]
segment like an official segment out of
it you know like we do a bon head of the
week we should do
it Michelle says I love Texas Paul well
maybe I can get her comment up here I
love Texas Paul he can farts when he
wants to yeah exactly that's what I say
freedom farts
right
yeah fartgate continued fartgate
continues
um Sig on YouTube says our farts are
powered by democracy that's right that's
right um Rob Robbie asked um on YouTube
will comr pile ever let Hunter testify
well I mean he's gonna have to at some
point they're not going to get out of
this thing right they're gonna have to
they are they already opened that
[__] Pandora's Box that's that's what
I that's what I keep saying is that I
want these [__] to show us who
they are I'm excited that comr pile is
the MAA is the is maa's [__] chairman
of the oversight committee nothing
better to point out the stupidity of
Maga and how ridiculous they are than
comr pile being their [__] chairman
of the oversight committee and
subpoenaing the president's son over a
[__] truck down payment good [__] him
do that yes come on Bring it on Bring it
the [__]
on um Joan ask where is Shaz Tony did he
find did you finally ban him no he's on
Facebook he's probably banned from
YouTube and um I I think Shaz is
probably some sort of disantis operative
because he I think he's from Florida so
he was a DeSantis operative and he he he
doesn't get paid to come comment on
YouTube he doesn't get paid to come
comment on Twitch and since I'm banned
from Facebook then he can't get paid to
comment on the Tony Michaels podcast so
why would he come over to YouTube and
comment on Tony Michaels podcast when
he's paid to comment over on Facebook
that's what leads me that's the evidence
that I have now I don't know this for
sure but that's just the evidence that I
have I mean if he really was a true
troll of the show wouldn't he come over
to YouTube I mean you know I guess
that's a good question
too um a lot of people we talking about
the court case I think this is what ask
on YouTube the court crew is hanging
around so who knows what's next I I
think there's supposed to be some sort
of movement apparently Trump had some
sort of accounting witness today and
it's one of the things that he came out
and said I'm not going to play that [__]
number one if he had anything relevant
to say in the courtroom they would move
those [__] microphones closer to that
fat [__]
buffoon you know what I mean or he would
get closer to the mics for [__]
sake
ridiculous
um HB radio Nation here on Twitch says
release the farts release the
farts oh boy he's gonna be mad at me
free the farts they say free the
farts Julie says maybe Texas Paul should
have a fart jar I don't know these
answers to these questions you guys are
asking them in the chat I I don't know
but um Amanda apparently farts rainbows
and pisses democracy there you go that's
the way to do it here's the question
that I have for you Amanda can you fart
rain rainbows and piss democracy all at
the same time because that would be a
[__] trick wouldn't
it let's see what else we got
here fartgate
continues um Brandon Woods now here on
YouTube says Shaz said democrats should
be jailed Facebook says it is not
against Community standards so
apparently Brandon has U tried to report
Shaz for saying these things now Shaz
doesn't just troll my show that's the
other evidence that I have is people
have sent me uh screenshots of him
trolling other commentators like David
Pacman um Midas some Midas Touch shows
um I believe he was trolling some tyt
stuff or you know again and and the
strategery the strategery of this is
Facebook right and that's where they
have Shaz and that's why I believe he's
a paid
operative he's paid to go comment in
Facebook and that's why he's on Facebook
that's why you don't see him in my
YouTube channel because he doesn't make
any money coming over to YouTube and
commenting on my YouTube he would just
get paid to comment on my Facebook and
because I pointed him out and you
remember that one day I pulled up a
comment he was claiming in the chat that
he would pay me to shut up how much
money would it take for me to not do my
show and I showed him my my patreon
honestly I'll show you my patreon too I
mean hey [__] you pay me you know what I
mean [__] you pay me if if if you want
me to shut up [__] you pay me here is
the um here's the get me to shut up um
um tier on patreon if they really want
to get with it it's the get set up you
know I should change this to [__] you
pay me um it's $50,000 a
mon they can pay me $50,000 a month and
I'll shut the [__] up sure why
not I should raise this to a 100,000
actually you know what we should do like
a poll or something and see what we
should raise this to how much would it
take for you guys to say yeah that's
probably enough for Tony to shut the
[__] up and you know here's the rub is I
wouldn't I would shut the hell up but
the thing is is I would just pay someone
else to come and do what I
do or or maybe we could just build ey
Tony
damn yep see rat's got it rat's on it he
wants to build he wants to build a AI
Tony that way it's not actually me
talking it's AI so what am I supposed to
do you know you're paying me all this
money but it's not me talking it's it's
a [__] robot talking that'd be kind
of cool actually you know what I mean
what do you think about that we built a
an ey Tony to sit and
talk I don't know I don't know let's see
what else do we got we're at we're at
the top of the hour sounds like I need a
coffee coffee break too Robbie asked um
here will Grandpa poopy pants testify in
the New York trial I don't think he's
testifying today I don't think there's I
don't I don't think
anyone's I don't think anyone's saying
maybe they are but I think the reports
this morning were that he wasn't
actually going to um testify himself
it's an expert that they have and the
thing that they they're G to claim is oh
the New York attorney general has used
this person as an expert but I mean this
is paid defense expertise so in other
words the defense has paid this person
to have this point of view so it's not
going to work I mean it it may lower the
amount of money that the judge decides
um to to actually take from Donald Trump
as a penalty for his fraud but he's
already been he's already been shown to
commit fraud um it's just a a matter of
how much money the judge is going to uh
charge him for the fraud that he
committed so if that makes sense right
and I'm no lawyer I don't need to be one
by the way um Melanie ask would I visit
poopy pants in prison oh if I could
that'd be great would when that be
fantastic but Tony Michaels showed up to
to [__] visit Grandpa poopy pants in
a federal
pen that might be all right I mean I
guess that's a big question too is is he
actually gonna go to a prison right like
he's got 91 felonies against him So
eventually he's gonna cop one of these
felonies and he's GNA be charged with
some he's going to be sentenced to some
sort of
time but the question is is how do they
imprison him right because he is a
former president like he's got Secret
Service detail and there's a lot of
legal questions around that but also the
Bureau of Prisons is the one who
actually uh incarcerates people who are
sentenced federally so what happens is
is a federal judge sentences you
to your time for the crime that you've
committed right that's the idea now a
federal judge has a lot of say and how
you can sometimes but the Bureau of
Prisons actually
decides uh the Bop as it's called The
Bop actually decides how you serve your
time in the Bop you talk about a [__]
slow bureaucracy and it's a slow clunky
bureaucracy and with intent uh with the
Bureau of Prisons so you know would I
visit him in a prison that's that's
that's kind of a a cute little piece of
content to you know think
about and me visiting Donald Trump in
prison um but but in reality I I don't I
actually that's a question that I still
have for myself I know he's I know he's
been charged indicted on federal crimes
he's going to be convicted of these
federal crimes and he's going to be
sentenced by a judge but I don't know
how the Bop I I I don't know it's it's
something that we haven't done before
like we haven't crossed this Rubicon
before that's why we should have never
elected the [__] idiot in the first
place but you know who listens to the
email lady you know what I mean
um pale Ryder says fart lives matter
yeah all all farts matter to be quite
honest they all
matter now you guys with the jokes you
guys with the
jokes um kayln and Patterson here says
Tony uh I think dims need to flood the
Zone on the right right-wing TV and
radio to spread our message what are
your thoughts about infiltrating the
bubble I I I I agree with you now
there's several ways to infiltrate the
bubble um the the best way to infiltrate
the bubble is get them on the defense
okay now when when like um Pete Buddha
judge is really good at this uh when he
goes on like Fox News he's he's really
good at keeping them on defense but the
narrative has to be on defense and when
you have a a a Fox News host that's
pretending to be non-biased and they're
interviewing someone from the left and
and again Pete Budaj is really good at
this at keeping the narrative on defense
as opposed to the person on defense
right so there there is a difference um
like if I'm I'm and that's why it that's
why it does no good for like for me to
have a right winger on my show um to
[__] you know it's it's kind of nice
to show you how you how you go at them
but you got to go at it's not that
person exactly it's their narrative and
you notice when I do that uh when I get
like a a clip of someone whether it's
Fuentes or Charlie Kirk or [__] poop
M Ron or Grandpa poopy pen himself um
today we'll have one of Chris Christie
and Rama rad damad dingdong V but I mean
you gotta you gotta really attack their
narrative so that that's a huge thing
when you're talking about spreading the
message and infiltrating the bubble and
the reason why it's important H to
attack their narrative not necessarily
the person is because you got to get
their narrative on defense that's why
it's actually working all these
right-wingers have to defend that Trump
isn't a Nazi like that's that's the [__]
they're talking about on right-wing
media Trump is a Nazi Trump is a Nazi
Trump is a Nazi is Trump a Nazi is Trump
a Nazi is Trump a fascist is he gonna be
a dictator is that what he wants to be
like that's the [__] we want they want
we want them to have to be on defense
about
that and they are so we're winning that
battle um so that that that bubble is
infiltrated because they're on that
defense but we have to keep them there
and they're gonna they're going to be
[__] just jerking off and wetting the
bed oh man they're going to be wetting
their pants over this project 2025 stuff
come uh next year they're going to be
running on it a lot of a lot of a lot of
Liberals are like oh no they're not
going to run on that that shit's overt
fascism I'm like what are you talking
about that's the [__] they want they
want project
2025 they're going to run on it I'm
telling you right now they're going to
be saying We Love Project 2020 and and
they're slow walking to that
point right they can't just be in love
with it they gotta get all their again
they gotta feed the sheep the Sheep food
right get them to eat get them nice and
fat with the Sheep food and then
convince them that they're not nice and
fat from the Sheep food that it's
something else
so just hang on to that thought uh let's
see what else do we got here I like
shoot the [__] should we just do this
the whole [__] show I don't know um
should we do
that I got these clips to show you
though so we got to get to these clips
we got to get to these clips I really
want to show you this stuff but you guys
are so good with all the questions
um oh fartgate is real in the chat you
guys
are H Tony TB says Tony if Glenn 2 farts
does Glenn one smell it I have no idea
that is a really good [__] question
I'm not sure the difference between
Glenn one and Glenn 2 but it may maybe
if Glenn two farts Glenn one might smell
it that's a pretty good [__] point
there oh my God you guys with the
fartgate stuff in the in the chat I'm
here for it I'm here for it I may have
caused it well I didn't cause it it was
you know it's like a breakfast or
burrito or something that caused
fartgate I just I just clipped what the
breakfast burito C I don't know what he
ate that morning I have no idea I have
no
idea oh boy I'm GNA be in big trouble
people are goingon to be mad at
me there's a few people are G to be mad
at
me oh what do we got here oh
boy oh yes yes I forgot it is December
7th rats pointing out that it is
December 7th I don't know if you guys
know what December 7th is but in 1941
there was a bunch of fascists that
attacked our country and Drew us into a
second world war where we went over and
we kick fascist ass you remember that
when when when
antifa got got all dressed up and went
over to Europe and in the South Pacific
and whipped fascist ass whipped a bunch
of Nazi ass antifa did that in Pearl
Harbor yeah Susan G points out that it's
82 years ago today here's a couple
images um
from there now it's kind of funny my my
grandfather actually served in the
United States Navy and he was stationed
uh in Southern California but he was um
at Pearl Harbor just months before and
he was sent back to uh San Diego before
so my um fortunately my grandfather was
not at parl Harbor when the Japanese
attacked it on December 7th 1941 um
here's a couple more images uh from from
from Pearl Harbor this this is also an
image here um there from
1941 were thousands of uh US soldiers
Navy men and civilians nurses and people
at Pearl Harbor died because of the
attack on Pearl Harbor that day um but
that may be the reason why I'm here is
because just luck would have it that he
would be sent back to San Diego months
before Pearl Harbor actually happened so
um here is the another image of the
Pearl Harbor attack on the Airfield
there there's actually a really good um
Netflix series on Pearl Harbor and kind
of the Tik Tock of it if you guys want
to go watch
that here is here's some more images and
we have some sound there from from Pearl
Harbor of one of the car being exploded
that day uh by the Japanese fascist and
the allies of of Nazi Germany Japan um
and it's you know it's it's kind of
weird that we we have to sit here on a
day like today December 7th 1941 82 days
after the bombing at Pearl Harbor and
um that we have to still fight these
[__] idiots and still fight this
ideology but that's the point is you
can't stuff this stuff back into bags
right like you can't put a feral cat
back in a bag once it's out you have to
you have to keep you have to you have to
keep fighting it right because you can't
kill an idea folks you can't you can't
kill an idea it'll always be an idea um
I mean I know they try to kill ideas by
Banning books and [__] and trying to
rewrite history and whitewash history
and and trying trying to do it that way
but listen the [__] truth always
comes to the Forefront it always does
every single [__] time no matter what
you try to do or how you try to spin it
or how you try to [__] get in
there but it it's it's just a matter of
making sure that you're with the truth
the most part of the time right um
someone brings up staral here on Twitch
makes a good point Tony sometimes we all
just have to agree to disagree and I
guess that you know that's a good
point again I I'm not against descent
that's why I say doubt me because you
should doubt me to some degree you
should doubt this [__] I'm saying go
find out for yourself use your [__]
thinky space that space where holds your
brain and go use that and use your
critical thinking skills to go find out
if I'm right and if you should be
doubting what I'm saying on this issue
or that issue
you should do it it's fine we're we're
not always going to agree you if if if I
sit here and believe that I'm going to
get thousands and thousands of people
that agree with every [__] thing I
say I'm [__] delusional and if you
believe that I'm GNA sit here and say
every single thing that you believe
you're [__] delusional it's
delusional to believe that we're all
going to believe exactly the same way I
mean most of us are going to be on the
same page because we have a certain set
of principles right and I believe that
my audience has a really certain set of
principles and that certain set of
principles is that democracy is better
than autocracy that you guys believe
that the freedom and rights that are
granted to us by our constitution is the
vehicle that delivers us Liberty and
Liberty is the goal Liberty is the
[__]
goal it's not always 100% attainable I
mean we want things like equity and
diversity equ equity in this country
that leads to more freedoms that leads
to those rights being Beed to more
people through the Constitution which
gives every single person in this
country more and more liberty no matter
what how you feel about things even if
you hate diversity even if you hate
equity and and inclusion even if you
[__] hate those thing in your maganga
when those things come to the Forefront
and constitutionally are given to every
single person you the person who hates
those things have more freedom and you
obtain more Liberty that's the whole
[__] point that's the whole point now
now they get confused white Christian
nationalists and white people in this
country surely get Liberty and
privileged
confused like that's the one thing that
no one kind of says especially [__]
white people especially around other
[__] white people is most white
people let me give you a clue most white
people in this country get privilege and
Liberty confused those two things are
not the same they are not the same just
because you have some sort of white
privilege doesn't mean that it's liberty
okay it's privilege and really honestly
a lot of time privilege is the opposite
of Liberty because when you receive
privilege a lot of times other people
are getting their Liberty stomped on
which is the opposite of Liberty you
know what I mean so you just got to kind
of look through you know a certain
lens a certain lens to see
clearly and see the principles of
democracy and see how how with the
Constitution granting us freedoms and
rights is the perfect vehicle to deliver
us Liberty now it's not perfect
democracy isn't perfect it's not
designed that way if it were perfect we
would completely complely be
[__] it is designed for us to [__]
come
together and to do Democratic things
together right that's the whole [__]
design it's for us we the people the
government we are the
government to make sure that we use our
time here on this this [__] swinging
little ball and it's a ball it's round
Sphere for all the flat earthers out
there to use our time to advance and
progress Equity equality diversity and
making sure that everyone every single
[__] I don't care if they live
here I don't care if they're in Gaza I
don't care if they're in Israel I don't
care if they're in Ukraine or Russia
Mexico Canada I don't give a [__] where
they are that they receive the most
Liberty that they have now in this
country inside our borders we have a
constitution and we must defend that
Constitution because that Constitution
is the document it is the thing that
delivers us our rights and our freedoms
and we must fight to defend it and the
best weapon we have is the ballot and
the best way to use the ballot as a
weapon to defend democracy is to
engage engage engage engage and defend
your [__]
positions rather you agree with me or
disagree with me Defending Your
positions and when those positions
become indefensible right-
Wingers your goal should be to make them
defendable so let's hold them to account
let's keep them on defense let's keep
them defending it let's get to some
clips don't go anywhere we'll be right
back with some of these clips right
after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast fellow Patriots what would you
do if there was a trump supporter right
in front of you crying in pain because
they have to live under communist
tyranny we know what you would do you'd
reach out and give that true American in
a hand now here's your chance for only
$50 a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only $50 a day recurring and it means
you'll get these Trump supporters the
critical help they so desperately need
to survive under this false regime
please donate now because those Trump
supporters you just saw can't wait
another
moment [__] them [__] [__] them [__]
them [__] them [__] we're back to the
Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast welcome back to the show
oh that was fun I think that was one of
the longest [__] shoot the [__] that
we have ever
done I like shooting the [__] with you
guys I really do all right let's get
this this flock of idiots from last
night um on on the debate stage let's
see I want to pick out some good ones
here um here's a good one here's Nikki
Nikki Haley if you're wondering if oh
man she 's going to really she's going
to really pose herself as a moderate and
and be able to beat Trump let's listen
to how she feels about Ronda sanz's
bigotry let's listen I actually said his
don't say gay Bill didn't go far enough
what I actually said his don't say gay
Bill didn't go far enough huh I actually
said his don't say gay Bill didn't go
far enough oh so his don't say gay Bill
didn't go far enough so Nikki Haley not
only doesn't want you to say gay but
that's not as far as she would go what
what the [__] is going on again they
always show their true colors when
they're trying to fight each other and
I'm talking about the Nazis fighting the
Nazis now this is some crazy [__] um
this is one of the best Clips I think
that comes out of last night to show the
true colors of some of these [__] Bon
heads specifically um radama
dingdong
v v radama dingdong listen listen to
this [__] trash this is [__] oh my
God qanon is a hell of a drug listen to
this Donald Trump attempted to take on
and if you want somebody who's going to
speak truth to power then vote for
somebody who's G to speak the truth to
you what so are we supposed to vote for
you dummy are we supposed to vote for
Trump now I've been saying this since I
heard VC for the very first time it was
in a Twitter space it was in one of
those [__] Mario spaces that I used
to speak in and I stopped speaking and
because there's a bunch of [__]
weirdos bunch of right- Wingers it's
just [__] it's a jerkfest over there
on his [__] on his on his Twitter
spaces the point is this this is the
first time I heard VC speak was on a
Twitter space and I said then I told
Gabe Sanchez in private we even said it
public here on the show that Verve rad
damad dingdong here is a [__] plant
for the Trump campaign and I don't know
who the [__] funds him but it smells
like Russian salad dressing that's all
I'm
saying you guys ever had Russian salad
dressing it's what it smells like to me
I don't know keep going though rad
damama
ding-dong why am I the only person on
the stage at least who can say that
January 6 now does look like it was an
inside
job January 6 was an it was an inside
job he was the president he was inside
the government he controlled the
executive branch they tried to use
members of Congress who were elected to
congress to overturn the government it
was an inside job you dumb
[__] what the f what in the [__]
don't they get I I can't tell you now
left Wingers are gonna [__] go out
there and be like oh my God v ramaswami
he's a [__] idiot he thinks January 6
was an inside job I mean I know what
he's talking about he's talking about
the [__] FBI and law enforcement doj
and and the Biden White House who wasn't
in the [__] office and Obama and
whatever the [__] he wants to say but it
was a goddamn inside job now he's trying
to convince people that it's the Deep
state that was in on it but it's a
[__] Inside Job [__] yes it
was an inside job the president of
United States trying to overturn the
government he was trying to use the
executive branch he was trying to use
[__] members of Congress he was
trying to use [__] state legislators
he was trying to use fake electors in
these states he was trying to convince
Governors to [__] not certify the
votes inside inside the government it
was an inside job from Republicans they
were trying to [__] steal your
goddamn vote FC you stupid [__] yes it
was an inside job it's just not the
inside job that you're [__] wetting
your pants over that the government lied
to us for 20 years about that the the
government lied to us for 20 years oh
this is where he rounds out the [__]
911 listen to this does look like it was
an inside job that the government lied
to us for 20 years about Saudi Arabia's
involvement in 911 about Saudi Arabia's
involvement in 911 he said she's so full
of [__] guess guess who guess who
actually [__] outed that the
government knew to some degree that it
was Saudi Arabia involved in 911 it was
a Democratic Senate
folks I don't know if you know that or
not but if you want to go look it up you
[__] can I know that most Americans
and especially radama dingdong here
can't remember [__] contemporary
issues but it was [__] Democrats in
the [__]
Senate who made sure that the American
people knew that it was Saudi Arabia
behind 911 you dumb son of a [__] how
don't these people know this [__] before
they say this [__] out loud are you
[__] kidding me now this is how I
knew that rad damama dingdong was a
[__] joke from the very beginning
from the very [__] beginning I knew
he was a joke because he didn't even
know he had no clue that John KY the
Democratic nominee from two thou in the
election in 2004 that lost to George
Bush had a vice presidential person on
the ticket and that person was charged
and went to federal
court and was exonerated in open court
about about [__] corruption in
politics and money in
politics didn't even [__] know that
had no clue no clue that the standard
who was going to be the standard Bearer
his his name was
Edwards no one knows who the [__] that
is anymore especially radam and dingdong
because he [__] doesn't have he
doesn't have the ability to pluck his
head out of his ass far enough to know
the truth and know reality that the
great replacement Theory is not some
Grand right-wing conspiracy theory Jes
of the democra part's platform that's
right great replacement Theory the the
Nazi theory that we're trying to bring
immigrants here to to replace white
people this is so [__]
dumb this guy this guy whose parents
immigrated here the reason why he's
[__] here is replacement
Theory this [__] piece of trash
godamn qanon is a hell of a drug the
2020 election was indeed stolen by big
Tech that the 2016 election the one that
Trump won for sure was also one that was
stolen from him by the National Security
establishment did you hear that the only
one he won for sure was 2016 and it was
trying to steal from him from the
National Security establishment which
Trump became president but 2020 election
was stolen by big Tech even even even
though re re ramaswami radama dingdong
here has benefited from Big Pharma and
big Tech this guy's such a [__]
walking contradiction and a walking
fraud okay that actually put the Trump
Russia collusion hopes that they knew
was false there's a reason why I'm the
only person on the stage who can say
these things that's what it's gonna take
not people who were licking his boots
one time and now Monday morning
quarterbacking and criticizing when it's
convenient what what what what what
looking whose boots is he's like vote
for Trump because V ramaswami says so
what are who are you what are you
running for man he literally literally
listen to listen to the round out here
at the end about the boot licking listen
to what he says and who he points to and
what he says about boot licking listen
you can say these things that's what
it's gonna take not people who were
licking his boots one time licking his
boots one time licking his boots one
time
so v r ramaswami rad damama ding-dong
here is [__] upset that the other
three candidates on stage at at one time
lick Trump's boots but they're not
full-time boot lickers they won't lick
his boots now he's really upset about
that vote for Trump because VC is a boot
licker is that what he's saying
quarterbacking and criticizing when it's
convenient criticizing him when it's
convenient so VC who are you running for
is it Trump 2024 or what the [__] are
you talking about man and again the
media goes off the rails about this guy
um thinking that the the January 6 is an
inside job it was a [__] Inside Job
members of Congress the president United
States the vice president United States
were crying out loud was trying to run
around trying to figure out how to
overthrow the government for Donald
Trump without going to
prison the [__] out of here it was an
inside job you goddamn right it was an
inside job the Republicans that were
elected to our government was trying to
steal our government away from us you
don't get more Insider than
that but the thing that the media missed
in this clip is that ve V raas Swami is
a bootlicker he's like they were
bootlickers at one time and they're not
anymore but vote for Trump because I'm a
bootlicker or some [__] I don't know
what the [__] he's talking about you try
to [__] figure it out and again of
course everyone's [__] distracted by
the fact that this guy's just puking up
[__] conspiracy
theories right but he's just all he's
doing is spreading a narrative he's
saying the [__] that's on your
Papa's Facebook page that's all Russian
propaganda that's all thex's [__]
goal is is to spread Russian propaganda
to a bunch of [__] internet in cells
that are on elon's [__] xchan that's
it
period now if you want to watch
something really good with rad damama
dingdong here there's no better example
of how to [__] handle a son of a
[__] like this than how Chris Christie
does it now yeah I'm gonna say [__] that
you folks are not gonna like with this
clip I'm warning you I'm warning you and
I've already started to say it today um
and I'm [__] dead serious about it
I'm dead [__] serious about this idea
that Chris Christie could beat Joe Biden
it is a [__] possibility now they
don't worry I know a people like Tony
don't give them that [__] idea
they're too stupid to [__] believe me
anyways right they're too dumb to
[__] take my advice are you kidding
me do you think manga's gonna wake up
tomorrow and go holy [__] Tony Michaels
said it let's do that I'm just giving
you the [__] facts
here I'm just giving you the [__]
facts and there ain't no way there ain't
no way that you can get me to believe
that Chris Christie wouldn't be a damn
good Contender for the middle part of
the country's vote that moderate vote
those Republicans that [__] hate
Trump that [__] hate him that don't
want to vote for him even though they'll
vote for him they don't want to vote for
him they he would beat Joe
Biden staral says you plant the seed of
thought no I'm not planting the seed of
thought to them I'm trying to tell y'all
I'm trying to tell you all the
threat I'm trying to tell y'all the
threat U because watch this clip if you
don't believe me watch this clip okay
you say this you do this you do this at
every debate you go out on the stuff and
you say something all of us see it on
video we confront you out on the debate
stage you say you didn't say it and then
you back away and I want
to I'm not done yet now
[Applause]
look this is the fourth debate the
fourth debate that you would be voted in
the first 20 minutes as the most
obnoxious blo hard in
America Chris Christie attacks U radam
ding Hong dingdong here appropriately
Cynthia says christe will not be
nominated you're right yeah chrisy
cannot get nominated in the Republican
party no [__] way no [__] way can
he get nominated Republican party I
actually believe that Chris Christie
knows that now I think what Chris
Christie is doing is he's positioning
himself to run in
2028 that that that that's what I'm
that's what that's what I'm trying to
tell you is that Chris Christie is
positioning himself to run in 2028
against Gavin Nome okay now I I don't
know that Chris Chrissy can beat Gavin
Nome I don't know that and really I
don't give a [__] at this point about
2028 the most Focus I want to have on is
the next [__] election because it's
the most important election of our
democracy's life we'll worry about that
one when we cross that [__] Bridge Mr
bridg gate
but here's the thing here's the thing
that I want you to understand about
about how politics works and how
elections work is there are groups out
there that are seeking candidates that
can run against Joe Biden okay and we
know that no labels is one of them now
Chris Christie doesn't have any kind of
indication that he's willing to jump off
the Republican primary uh ticket and go
to some place like No Labels now we saw
that Joe Mansion [__] the bed right Joe
Mansion decided he wasn't going to run
for Senate anymore and he would use that
to propel himself as the No Labels
nominee and that [__] to [__] bet
immediately there was no [__]
appetite for Joe Mansion to be anything
but [__]
retired
okay so we have good luck there with no
labels now I I mean we got to keep an
eye on it because these [__] idiots
could still nominate someone is what I'm
saying okay and and Chris Christie here
and Liz Cheney ain't out ain't out of
the [__] sight for them to [__] with
this election but let let's keep going
here and watch Chris Christie absolutely
wad rad damad dingdong up here and dunk
him in the
[Applause]
trash I want to say something else we're
now 25 minutes into this debate and he
has insulted Nikki Haley's basic
intelligence not her positions her basic
intelligence she doesn't know regions
she wouldn't be able to find something
on a map that his three-year-old could
find look if you want to disagree on
issues that's fine and Nikki and I
disagree on some issues but I'll tell
you this I've known her for 12 years
which is longer than he's even started
to vote in a Republican
primary godamn see that that's what I'm
talking about is Chris Christie is a
master at this uh it's the one reason
why Chris Christie was the two-term
Republican governor in New Jersey even
with even even with his shitty policies
all the [__] that he did to New Jersey
he didn't he didn't do quite that great
with New Jersey he barely won his second
term but he did as a republican in New
Jersey and the reason why is is how good
he is at [__] tough guy politics okay
and and I and I I get I get that a lot
of people don't want me to say this [__]
out loud but hey folks it's the [__]
truth it's the [__] truth and if you
ignore the truth it might [__] bite
you in the ass okay it might just
[__] come back to bite you in the ass
and for us to stand around acting like
Chris Christie isn't skilled at this um
would be would be a dereliction of our
duty now we watched last week as poop
Matt Ron got his [__] ass handed to
him to someone else who is very good at
what Chris Christie does which is Gavin
Nome Gavin Newsome is another guy in
politics that is very good at this
stuffing people in a [__] Locker um
now Chris Christie has a little bit
different approach to it because he he
doesn't really use truth um to do this
he he uses the tough guy attitude and
toxic masculinity to kind of do it but
I'm telling you I know you may not
believe me when I say it but that
[__] skill is a [__] marketable
skill especially on the
right so we can't we can't lose sight of
this now Liz Cheney when I was talking
about Liz Cheney the other day knocking
on
her she ain't she ain't number one the
right she ain't got the [__] cahun
literally to be a nominee on the right
that's why Nikki Haley ain't gonna be
the nominee folks she's a woman I don't
give a [__] what Nikki says how she says
it where she says it I don't give a [__]
how [__] bigoted she gets she ain't
going to be the nominee because she's a
[__]
woman this party is not
that party is not going to nominate a
woman as the President of the United
States anytime [__] soon it just
ain't going to
happen it ain't going to
happen but I'm telling you we have to
keep our eye on what the truth is and
the truth is is Chris Christie is a is a
real
threat um to our to the pro-democracy
Coalition keeping its Coalition together
okay that's what I'm trying to tell you
that's what I'm trying to point out to
you here U but it's just the [__]
truth it's just the truth that I'm
telling you and no one else is going to
tell you this [__] no one else is gonna
[__] go out on a limb to say the [__]
I'm saying now Chris Christie is a
[__] [__]
box he's a [__] scumbag and half the
[__] he says he doesn't believe because
if he did believe it he'd have done been
anti-trump this entire [__] time he
would have never stood behind Trump ever
he would never begged to be in his
[__] Administration he would have
never went and caught Co and almost died
to try to [__] prep this guy for
debates against Joe Biden so that way
Donald Trump could be dictator and King
of the United States okay Chris Christie
is no [__] angel here [__] Chris
Christie [__] him but I'm just trying to
tell you and do not do not do not think
that Chris Christie is irrelevant in our
American politics these other [__]
chuckleheads like Ronda Sanz irrelevant
he's too much of a
weirdo he doesn't know what the [__]
he's doing he has no ground in principle
and he doesn't know how to pretend V
ramaswami is a complete [__] fraud
100% full stop rad damad dingdong
doesn't know what the [__] he's talking
about Nikki Haley is a [__] shill and
the problem is is she's a woman she
can't win a goddamn Republican
presidential primary she's a [__]
woman and I know you think I'm talking
bad about her because she's a woman but
I'm not I [__] I think that women should
be in more power honestly it should be
one of the only qualifications that we
have [__] we would be a lot further
ahead in progression if we had women
running this country the last goddamn
hundred years than a bunch of old
wrinkly white [__] ball sacks okay
but the reality is in the Republican
party in this time in this moment in
history there's no [__] way they're
going to let Nikki Haley a woman be
their goddamn [__] nominee it ain't
going to happen but let's continue let's
watch Chris Christie finish up damaging
and destroying V ramaswami
here and while we disagree about some
issues and we disagree about who should
be president United States what we don't
disagree on is this is a smart
accomplished woman you should stop
insulting so I'm going to take this
times first of all first of all the
first of all the first of all but you
saw you saw Chris Christie there
brilliantly
brilliantly brilliantly courtt Nikki
Haley's support now Nikki Haley thinks
that she won this but Chris Christie won
her supporters watch this
[__] while we disagree about some issues
and we disagree about who should be
president United States what we don't
disagree on is this is a smart
accomplished women you should stop
insulting to take this now in that
moment here's what Chris Christie knows
and Nikki Haley doesn't uh you can look
at Nikki Haley here and she thinks
that's good for her what what Chris
Christie understands that Nikki Haley
doesn't because she's an idiot she truly
is an idiot I don't care I don't care if
Chris Chrissy would attack me because
I'm insulting her intelligence I'm
insulting her intelligence she's a
[__] bonad okay she's a [__]
bonehead what Chris Christie understand
understands that Nikki Haley does not in
this moment is that she won't be the
nominee because she's a woman but Chris
Christie can [__] co-opt the idea
that that those Republicans that would
vote for a woman because now we don't
have to vote for a woman we got a guy in
Chris Christie who defends Nikki Haley
the woman you see how he's doing that
you see how Chris Christie knows his
[__] here Chris Christie knows his [__]
he's no [__]
dummy this guy is a goddamn political
Juggernaut this guy is this guy has been
a two-term New Jersey Republican
Governor he's been in several
presidential races and got his ass
kicked and he's still relevant on the
national stage you gotta watch Chris
Christie you gotta watch that
[__] now rad damaad
dingdong radama dingdong is a [__]
idiot he's a fraud he's a phony and this
guy that I'm about to bring up knows
that he's a fraud and the phony because
me and him listen me and him heard him
for the very first time at the exact
same time in a Twitter space and Gabe
Sanchez um he was saying [__] then that
he would say the opposite now like oh
yeah oh [__] yeah this guy this guy
you're fraud you know V the fake flippy
floppy ramas Swami this man goes onto
these Twitter spaces early on uh doesn't
know a thing about politics loves to
quote history J you know he talks
Jefferson Washington Lincoln every any
any president or previous
lawmaker from the beginning of of when
this country was founded he will quote
misquote not understand the
quote and so when he goes into these
debates and it was funny because last
night I was watching a clip of Chris
Christie and I was like wait this sounds
so familiar and then I realized that I
[__] said it months ago wait wait
wait I have the clip hang on let me let
me find that clip uh because you said it
on a it's not just him Chuck Todd is now
I'm like oh my God thank you people I
don't know if you're watching the show I
don't know if you're watching the show
or if you're now coming to the
realization of who vake really
is but Jesus Christ I mean you watch oh
we were all over him me and you we're
all over this guy from the first time we
heard him speak like I remember he was
speaking in the space and I think I
think we might have both been on stage
and we're texting each other in
background I'm like who is this [__]
fraud how is he's got to be he's got to
be in in this for Trump he's a trump
plant there's no way he's not a trump
plant he's the first what I and I've go
a I'm writing a what was that on this um
on what happened last night but also in
general like this guy he's not a serious
candidate I've said it before and on top
of that when you look at what he was
saying and how he was performing on
stage and all the way back to the
beginning because we were talking about
this is like this guy doesn't know what
he's talking about
he uh has no Insight but he is the and
what I say in the episode is he's the he
was the first one to show up to Donald
Trump's arraignment and he's the last
one to ever criticize Donald Trump when
it comes to policies but he calls
himself he says Donald Trump is the
greatest president of 21st century but
I'll be better well well if that's the
case then why would you need him need to
run it's funny um you say that because I
showed the clip earlier where he's
talking about all all these other people
were one-time boot lickers but I'm he
basically says I'm a full-time boot
licker I mean do say that out loud but
that's what he means let's listen let's
listen to how they're copycatting you
now this is a what was that when is this
from what when is this this is from like
end of August uh beginning of September
Okay let's listen but's debate style is
very simple and predictable much like
the GOP he makes absurd statements
denies he made them claims are out of
context spliced or manipulated by the
mainstream media and then plays victim
does that remind you of anyone but
anyway V's main debate tactic is to
filibuster so he can prevent anyone from
getting their point across because if
they can't finish their argument then V
believes that he won however it actually
makes V look like a petulant child who's
too afraid to have a real conversation
when challenged about his lackluster
qualification I I gotta say something
about this clip then I want I want
people to notice here um your set is
getting better and better I I just want
to it has changed I like I like that set
there go I know it was simple but at the
same time ready watch this ready let's
see what's what's going on oh he's got
lighting effects look at this folks Gabe
Sanchez with the lights you know we're
we're getting there small improvements
we're we're tinkering son of a [__] I
want to show you there's another well go
ahead go ahead no I was gonna say so
that's that clip are you going to play
the Chris Christie clip well I I what
the clip I want to play because I have
I've made it to Chris Christie but I
haven't made it to poop mat Ron yet um
so I really want to get to poop mat Ron
now there wasn't a there wasn't a lot of
great moments for poop mat Ron in the
debate but every the thing that I like
best about poop matron is every time he
goes on these debates he ends up on Fox
and Friends the next morning in some
sort of Diner and he's claiming he won
right he's like yeah I [__] won like
no you didn't you I mean who is it last
night that's or rather someone this
morning was saying that Rhonda they're
like Ronda santis is the clear winner
[__] who oh it was it wasn't on Fox News
it was
um Jenna
Ellis she said I think I think what she
said was last night clear winner was uh
I'll try to find the Tweet but let me
let me ask you a question about Jen ow
is she is she has she pled guilty to to
lying has she pled guilty to that I just
want to make sure the same okay I just
want to make also she also had to admit
that she lied at least 10 times right so
she didn't lose about the 2020 election
I just want to make sure this the same J
Ellis we're talking about here but this
is the same Poop Map round look at this
freeze frame of poop mat Ron this guy is
such a [__]
weirdo Ron santis when he sees his life
flash before his eyes right well I think
this is like when when the actual
programming the fashion programming in
his um his Android um body that he wears
the skin suit over I think that's when
it glitches error cannot cannot compute
there is an error oh no oh no check your
high heels check your high heels but
here's Ron the santis this is only a
9-second clip this is some wild [__] now
like we've been talking about this for a
long time about how these fascists
especially Ronda santis and and and
these Ronda santis types like Matt Walsh
and others like they go straight to kids
wieners like when you're talking like
what how did you go from this to kids
wieners like what are you doing it's
like a predator drone man that's coming
in [__] weird which would make sense
you know predator drone yeah well it
does make make sense here but yeah they
got loot they they don't even no no one
has to make mention of the subject and
they will find a way straight to and
Target and be like kids Jia kids J tell
you listen to this um you know you can't
take a 12-year-old and get him a tattoo
it's just you got to be a certain age
but yet somehow you can chop off their
private parts give me a break and you
know what what the what the [__] like
listen all right they're so all you got
to do is just a little and I know I know
manga idiots and people who support
Ronda Sanders don't do a lot of reading
apparently um it's kind of obvious but
all you got to do is do a little bit of
reading just a little bit of reading and
understand that transgender people like
the last thing the last part of their
transition yeah is to do anything with
their genitalia and the first thing
these people think about is okay
transgender person it has to be a man
who wants to be a woman because that's
what I'm scared of because I don't want
to go to a bar and pick up on a woman
and find out that she has a wiener or
once had a wiener I'm terrified of that
because that might make me think I'm gay
and then and they go all
yeah it's not that part it's that they
it's that they're afraid that they'll be
attracted to a transgender woman yeah
and they will go oh my God [__] we
like the same things we're [__] Jing
we're good man we are you two you and I
we are vibing right now then they
realize oh my
God they have a penis right but it's not
just they have a penis it's oh my God
that is way bigger than mine [__] uh
well you know what's weird though they
go from that fear
to children like that's the thing that
really [__] with my head when I start
to think about how fast they go to this
stuff is they go from their fear of what
you're just saying to children and I'm
like what the how in the [__] one is how
are you [__] doing this [__] how do
you get there but they love they love to
talk about it's the genitalia being
chopped off a 12-year-old no one is
doing that no one is doing that and the
idea that they're going to fearmonger is
because again they're afraid they've
even said this is this is their Hill
that they're going to die on this is
their their Civil War that they are
going to go up against which is they
will not let innocent children
be the victims of
adult
um
manipulation persuasion uh let me let me
ask you Gabe let me ask you you were
born once weren't you
you were born in a hospital probably
yeah um you were born in this country
there's a practice that goes on this
country in hospitals when boys are
born um it's actual gen genital
mutilation they they cut your fores
screen off your penis um they actually
use a knife to cut off part of your dick
yeah um so let me ask you and and I
don't mean to OU you here on the show
but um are you are you a victim of
childhood genital mutilation I I am I am
you know they took they took the hood
and they pulled it back you know right
they so so they made sure to cut the
hood off the hoodie is what you're
saying yeah it's just it's just it's
just a crew neck you know I just I think
I think this stuff is so weird right I
think this star gal says it's just skin
Tony right it's all just skin is it
right I mean it's all just skin like
when when when Elon Musk gets hair plugs
in his head skin to appear to have hair
on his head skin that's you know that's
just skin and that's just that's another
[__] when when you want when you want
your your chest to look bigger the skin
on your chest to look better and more
expanded like there's more muscles so
you get that I mean it's all just skin
is it a that a that what it is I mean
it's but but that I mean you make a good
point here is that as a child you know I
I didn't you know I don't care either
way but it's one of those things where
it's like I didn't have a say so if you
use their logic and their re and I use
logic very Loosely here
a lot
critical skills if you use their logic
then you could go all the way back and
say well it's not something that you
should do though they would say oh well
I'm you know I'm a Christian and that's
what we do or I'm Jewish I that's what
we do or like whatever it might be but
you look there's a lot of people that
aren't for that like they don't yeah
they don't circumcise because they're
against it and there's a lot of reasons
to be for it and a lot of reasons to be
against it right and you can have those
arguments just like you can have an
argument for a child who is transgender
who's in their teenage years to talk
about how they feel and they can talk
about that stuff without [__] getting
all weirded out about their genitals
like why are you doing that why the [__]
are you do they don't have any other
talking points you you see the hunter
Biden Joe Biden thing is failing
beautifully before our very eyes they
have no uh wait wait are you talking
about those illegal truck payments that
Hunter Biden paid back yeah all those
illegal truck payment those land swaps
oh sorry that's James comr um but also
it's you have to look at this and say
their only talking point their only
platform they had was we're gonna
impeach Joe Biden and that has failed
magnificently over the last year
watching them have control of the house
and now they're down to one or two
remaining majority members of the house
or even uh Mar Taylor green was like
hope no one dies Okie doie you know
that's like that's the point they're at
right now which is they need the
majority to make their fascist policies
go through which are also Dead on
Arrival when they get to the Senate and
even if they made it to the the White
House they would be dead on arrival and
they would be vetoed
but easy easy on the facts there easy on
the facts hurt their feel before I go to
my show I just want to say I got one
more clip I want to play before you show
so go ahead yeah yeah and that's all I
want to say is that's all they have they
have no talking points everything is
fear mongrain it's all this Narrative of
the woke left is causing these problems
but when you actually pull back the
curtain and look inside or the forkin
the forkin yeah or the hood
whatever not actually the things that
they're crying about ah go do your show
what was that live with gab Sanchez
right after this on YouTube twitch get
the hell out of here go to your show go
your show go to your show all right
everybody I got one more clip I want to
show you about Dick taster um that was
my take on um day one dictator this is
Trey Crowder's take on dictor I mean
dictator there's been a lot of talk
lately about a trump dictatorship I got
to say Trump makes sense as a dictator
and the word dictator makes sense for
Trump you I always thought that that
word was too silly and goofy sounding
for what it meant but with trump it it
actually works you know the man is both
a dick and a tater you can't deny it so
it seems like a distinct possibility yet
a huge chunk of our fellow Americans are
unconvinced and unconcerned by this
right now granted a full onethird of
Americans are actively salivating at
this Prospect at least I think they're
salivating it's hard to tell they tend
to drool a lot as a people and another
onethird of us are very very terrified
by this notion but it's that final third
that I'm fascinated by that third that
seems to think that type of thing just
can't happen here or they think that
like Trump and Biden are equally bad and
inconsequential options right like no
this is America it's not a dictator this
is the land of the free we sing it at
every football game that's got to count
for something right I think they also
think listen we already have one Trump
presidency and it didn't end in a
dictatorship so I think you're
overstating things oh yeah you mean the
Trump presidency which did end with a
failed attempt to overthrow democracy at
the 11th Hour that Trump presidency
you're okay with running that back
because you think Biden's too much of a
papa what dude this just like if you had
a if you had a babysitter who tried and
failed to abduct your child and later
you rehired that babysitter because her
replacement was taking too many naps
it's crazy the only reason this didn't
happen the first time around was because
of Trump's arrogance and incompetence
and yes those are immutable character
characteristics of the man but I still
don't think we should afford him the
opportunity to learn from his mistakes
and ah I I got to cut it there Tre CR
does such a good job go check out that
video on my Twitter page you can check
it out there just scroll on down you'll
find Trey you can find Trey CR
everywhere I always appreciate his
opinion but I wanted to show you how he
felt about the word dictator I said
dictator and I want to point out one
more comment uh Kell hel here on YouTube
says farts and forc skins for democracy
that's what we do here at the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday new Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube and twitch
sometimes Facebook when I'm not sent off
to the Googs over there we're so close
to 20,000 on YouTube hit that [__]
subscribe button if you're here and you
haven't hit it already pound that
[__] pound it that subscribe
button Gabe Sanchez what was that live
right now here on YouTube here on Twitch
don't go anywhere stick around for Gabe
Sanchez and tomorrow same time same
place surf sub [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking